okay so this is shark he's he's a mod
and
he's pretty good so this is a serious
game let's go e4 g6
okay so i'm modern now in the modern i'm
going to show you guys a good positional
line in the modern one
one good positional line in the modern
is to go c3
and uh what this move does to borrow my
favorite and
highly overused expression is um
is to create a situation where the
bishop bite on granite
by sun granite then we can develop the
bishop into this little crevice
in order to defend the other pawn so
the pawn chain protects the d-pawn the
bishop protects the e-pawn
now just complete our development
nothing nothing exciting about this now
we can play h3 to stop bishop g4 but
bishop g5 is sort of the
more aggressive continuation
i'm going to play a little bit faster
here because shark is super strong
um h6 now we drop the bishop back
e5 and now um
this is where things kind of get
interesting so
essentially he's threatening he takes d4
and then g5 g4 which will dislodge the
knight from its protection of the d-pawn
i hope that makes sense
so in this position we actually want to
take on e5
and then we want to take in order for
this bishop to remain
passive now we need to do something with
this knight what can we do with the
a39 uh b1 knight
where can we can we go to d2 is that
possible and
and if not where should we go yeah we
should go knight a3 frankfurt airport
right knight d2
uh loses the bishop queen takes d3
um and so what we do is we go knight a3
and the knight is coming out to c4
which is the ideal square because we are
attacking
we are attacking the frankfurt airport
analogy is what i always compare this to
the knight is bad on a3 but it's a
transit point to c4
okay so we're gonna go to c4 and we're
not you might look at this and say why
are we going to c4 we're not attacking
the spawn the queen is protecting it
well we're putting pressure on it it's
not only about attacking something you
also want to put pressure on stuff
that ties your opponent's pieces down
white is very slightly better here i
mean black and equalized
with good play now how should we go
about
increasing the pressure on black's
position well
we got a very aggressive idea here um
does anybody see this aggressive idea i
mean i'm not being very
specific in describing it but what i'm
noticing here is this pin
and what i'm also noticing is that we're
putting a lot of pressure on e5 if we
dislodge or displace that pawn we're
going to have e5 so let's just try f4
it's a risky move we're weakening our
king side that is true
but everybody should be able to see the
logic behind this movie if he takes the
pawn we
we push to e5 and uh we win the knight
because the knight can't move it's
pinned and if he goes g5 then we take
the knight attacking the queen
um those of you with the keem tactical i
may notice queen c5 check but
i have a very nice response to that
check what is white's response to that
check
and this is actually why i played f4
this is if this didn't
if this wasn't a possibility queen c5
would be the reputation
yeah bishop f2 so remember always that
uh the three ways to defend against the
check take the piece that's giving the
check not possible here
move your king and also to intercept the
check which is the
move that people forget about bishop f2
attacks the queen and then we're gonna
win e5 this might actually be black's
lesser evil
but it's still not plus and he loses his
central pawn
so very methodical play so far i mean
nothing crazy
okay so queenie eight is the right move
um obviously he gives up the pawn now
which way should we take the pawn
a lot of you guys might um might be
attracted to taking with the pawn
because it attacks the knight and i get
that but remember what i said yesterday
which is that um a move is not good
because it creates a threat
um and the problem with pawn takes e5 is
that he simply slides the knight back to
d7
and it opens the rook too but that pawn
on e5 is going to be very weak and it's
going to be attacked by three different
pieces simultaneously
so we're actually going to lose that
pawn right back
and so knight takes e5 is not as
satisfying it doesn't create a threat
but it's a lot more uh it's it's easier
for us to keep our extra fundamentals if
it should be seven attacks if one we
should defend it
he also wants to play rook d8 which
would pin the queen
so i'm going to violate a rule here
which is i always say
uh fulfill a task with the least
valuable piece so rookie one would be
the way to follow that rule but
i don't want him to pin my queen so
we're gonna go queen e2 here
so that rook d doesn't come with a pin
if that makes sense
um well he was attacking this pawn he's
got two attackers on the pawn and i've
got only one defender so we need to
protect the pawn and i'm doing it with
the queen to preemptively avoid the pin
okay so this is a really nice position
we're up upon we've got a nicely
centralized pieces a g5 so
this requires some calculation now the
purpose of this move is that if we
take the pawn on g5 the knight loses its
protection
of course things aren't that simple
because taking also attacks the knight
in after takes he's probably going to
take back on g5
so let's understand what happens there
now we open up the f file which is super
good uh but if we
visualize the position after fgh3 he's
got two pieces
we've got two pieces under fire the
bishop as well as the knight
do we have a way in that position to
defend both at the same time
because that would essentially justify
taking on g5
yes bishop g3 nothing particularly
extraordinary about this move we're just
protecting the knight
and we have opened up the f-file we have
forced him into a big weakening of his
king side
and we are still up upon so these kinds
of moves
um are stabilizing moves and they you
know they really
you know sort of protect everything
nicely
yeah rook f5 well rook five is a great
follow-up move but the rook f5 here
wouldn't protect the bishop right we
have two pieces hanging
we have to protect both of them at the
same time all right so here for example
okay he's not really attacking the
bishop we just got to keep an eye on it
um yeah just a box i'll do that after
the game so rook f5 here is a phenomenal
move
well bishop takes g5 he takes the the
knight and he protects his own knight
while he does that
yeah there's a there's a lot of good
moves here
so let me make a very russian school of
chess move rook five is good
well let's bring all uh all the ponies
to the you know
let's bring all of the all of the toys
to the nursery party let's go
rook 81 and this is a good stabilizing
move
you might look at this and say what is
the purpose like this pawn wasn't being
attacked but it's more about
overprotection it's more about making
sure that
our our foundation is solid before we
launch an attack against this king
prepare slowly attack fast um well rook
d1
we're trying to defend the pawn more
than i think the bishop isn't really
a problem here it's defended by two
pieces
um and yeah the queen can stop
babysitting the pawn later so it's a
move that is oriented toward the future
i don't know if this will come in handy
but i think it won't hurt
um it's just i mean you guys should just
visually be able to see that this move
just very harmoniously positions the
rook in
relation to the other pieces um
knight to d7 okay so
should we take the knight we could i
mean i don't
think that would be a bad idea but i
also think the night is a
pretty significant attacking asset and
as i look at this
one second guys i'm calculating yes we
have a tactic here
we have a tactic and i think we have a
very very pretty tactic actually
um we have we have a very pretty
sequence here
so what i notice here i mean his king is
very weak right so
we should already be primed
to look for tactics and when i say that
you should immediately
immediately be thinking about captures
and the only capture near the king side
is knight takes f7 you calculate this
okay rook f7 that positions the rook and
the king on the same diagonal do we have
a light squared bishop we do
we can simply position that bishop on c4
and uh
massacre him down that diagonal it's not
that simple
um and which is why you can also take
the rook first because he can't take
with the queen he's got to take with the
king
which you can then check on h5 but that
leads to unnecessary well maybe they're
necessary
that does lead to some complications um
now there is more to calculate because
what he can do here
right the attack on his rook is coming
from two different places
he can't cover the diagonal that the
bishop controls he can play bishop d5
will capture between e6 will capture the
queen
what he can do is cover the diagonal
that the rook controls which he does
but what happens here we take on f7 and
how do we follow this up this was an
important move for me to see when i was
playing knight takes f
otherwise he's got two pieces for a rook
and this wouldn't have been worth it
and you've got to be very careful about
these how should i put it
these combinations which try to win
material because if they backfire you
lose
all of your attack bingo now the queen
walks into another pin this i saw rookie
eight
how do we how do we do this what do we
do now is this a problem that he that
he's pinned
our queen well it's obviously it's not a
problem if it was a problem
we wouldn't have played this yeah so let
me think about this for a second
queen f2 is good because the knight
can't move we will capture his queen
otherwise we'll capture tonight now he
does have a
i think he has a move but it doesn't
really help him
i know that this move looks weird
because we are it
looks like we're unpinning is that we're
actually not we're just adding an
attacker
um we're just adding an attacker so the
knight still yeah bishop a6 is the
correct move i saw that he wins back the
exchange
but he remains down upon and his king
side is completely shattered
let me just write down the notes here
knight take knight g6 and we just need
to evaluate which bishop to take if we
take this bishop we allow the queen
trade we don't want to allow a queen
trade
now we can take this bishop how should
we capture this bishop and taking the
rook here also leads to simplification
which i don't want because i want to
attack him
why am i writing it down so i can answer
it after the game
rook in order to protect the spawn
okay bishop f8 never never forget to
check for threats
bishop c5 is a threat which means we can
cover that square
let's find an active defensive move by
by that i mean let's move
the queen away and attack something at
the same time the g5 is the obvious
target
um and so this is another thing where
people think of defending against
threats as a passive thing right you
need to move your king
or protect the square but you can defend
an attack at the same time
um i will explain that technical stuff
afterwards like why didn't we make the
other
move kartik so please don't worry about
it
yeah this bishop aid yeah this is an
ugly move
and there's many ways to go about
winning such a position i think
uh but we can go full
sort of crazy we can take on c7 that's a
cool that's a sexy move because he can't
take with the rook
what he can do there is he can
infiltrate to the second rank
but on the other hand i think it is a
sexy move so let's do it bishop takes c7
using the okay so he goes rook uh e2 but
we have another really cool move let me
play this move because we're short of
time
h4 why why are we playing h4
the reason should be obvious we're
trying to get rid of the spawn now if he
takes on h4 what i've noticed here
is that he's got a weak king and he's
got a type one undefended piece
that should always set the alarm bells
ringing in your head okay
um because a weak king is not only
susceptible to checkmate
it is also susceptible to double attacks
that should make intuitive sense queen
g4 check picks off the rook
okay so now we play queen takes g5 check
winning another pawn and now let's come
back maybe to f5 let me think about this
for a second now he wants to give us a
check on c5
that is not a dangerous check at all
but just to be very russian about it
let's go bishop e5
why because i want to cover this check
with my bishop and at this point we're
three pawns up so
at this point i don't mind
simplification um
you know i've i sort of draw the line at
being up a piece
when you're up three puns an end game is
going to be completely winning you don't
really need to bog yourself down with
all the
checkmating ideas so he goes rook takes
b2
um let's let's push our pawn up for now
let's go h5 just to create the
conditions for
okay so he's taking all of our pawns now
we're going to reorient for checkmate
in terms of reorienting yourself for
checkmate here we need more fuel to the
fire here so we need the rook
let's get this rook up into the attack
let's lift it up to g3
then we're going to try to go queen to
g6 jack and just crush him there
thank you attractive b i'm not playing
you know the most accurate moves for
sure but i i you know i think we're
maintaining a large margin here
and uh sometimes playing it a little bit
safer there's nothing wrong with that
let's
move away with check now let's complete
our rook lift
rook to g3 and i don't really see where
the mate is going to come from just yet
but i'm bringing
all of the rest of the pieces in and
that's going to be just crushing
okay
so we have i think a really cool move to
finish the game off
now what i'm noticing here yeah and this
is where like puzzle
puzzle rush comes in right this move is
a pattern recognition kind of move
queen ca check doesn't do as much as you
guys might think it does now what the
move that i think
wins the game if i've calculated it
correctly is rook to g7 bingo
after bishop takes g7 f takes g7 check
that exposes the attack on the queen
okay
why to move here rookie 5 is a nice
defensive move but i saw that
but now we need to look at the whole
board and queen h7 is just checking me
yeah that was a good game so
now the opening i think i explained
pretty pretty well i i don't think
i need to re-explain our development
moves knight a3
frankfurt airport going to c4 pressuring
the central pawn
and shark i think here you should
probably go g5 to break the pin even
though that is a weakening move but at
least you don't
you're not susceptible to f4
um now what would be a good move in this
position for white
what would be a good move in this
position for white
and i always say that you know when a
when a committal pawn move is made
you need to readjust you need to
understand
what the drawbacks are what squares have
been weakened and clearly the move g5
weakens the f5 square knights are the
default piece
to occupy an outpost so you should only
look for other pieces if knight can talk
you by the outpost and but here the
knight can you can go to e3
and black can move the knight aside and
the bishop protects f5 but this is what
i talked about earlier
you know even though white's knight
doesn't want to access the five
immediately it puts an incredible burden
on the
on the bishop which puts the bishop out
of commission it gives the bishop this
this
menial task that it's got to attend to
and
and that raises the strain on black
station i i think that makes i hope that
makes sense
um so it's not all about getting stuff
done it's all it's also about
threatening to get stuff done and
putting general strain on your
opponent's position
yeah okay so f4 is is the key move and
we talked about this so he takes f4 e5
wins the knight
and if he gives the check to one pin
himself the key move is bishop f2
and that attacks the queen and then
we're going to capture the knight
okay and this is your time to ask
questions so if you have questions about
a particular moment wait for that moment
to happen in the analysis
so we can keep things going smoothly
knight takes e5 fb5 he moves the knight
away and wins the pawn
and queen to e2 now there was a question
about queen to c2
and the really the only reason i think
the queen is just a little bit more
active on it so i think it's a little
bit more
um how should i put it uh it's
it's it's more in the game because you
know it
it's in the center and it it lines up
the battery with the bishop so you know
maybe you'll play bishop b5
maybe we should be following you at some
later point
queen to c2 it's it's sort of you know
it's
staring at the bishop in the pawn just
visually it's controlling less squares
um so don't overthink these kinds of
things um
so takes bishop to bishop to g3 once
again if you take the pawn you give up
the knight
and um you can't take the bishop because
the queen protects it what
would make you disregard the pawn and
mobilize the attack instead of defending
well when you feel like the attack is
strong enough to warrant that but it
isn't here we don't have enough pieces
in
if he takes he forward the knight where
exactly if he takes he forward the
knight here oh you're trying to open up
the attack and then well the problem
here is that takes
takes oh and we oh we've got to be very
careful here there's some beautiful
tactics
so in this position if we take the
bishop that's the obvious move it is a
bad one what does black do here if you
have
tac good tactical vision you will notice
that the queens are in a standoff and
white's queen is undefended and when we
played f4 we should have noticed
that that creates a weakness along this
diagonal put those two things together
bishop d4 check discover check winning
mcqueen
but white can turn the same tactic uh
around
and use that to uh defeat black what's
the line here
queens aren't a standoff which means we
gotta get black's queen onto an
undefended square
we have just the way to do that we take
the bishop black is either down a piece
or
he's got to walk into this check so
these tactical concepts aren't rocket
science
um but you have to actively apply them
you have to make the right observations
and
you know the calculation is not horribly
difficult if you kind of know how to
direct your thinking
okay we we get enough material for the
queen but white is trying to win here
not not equalized so you know it's
uh it's undesirable so rookie one knight
d7 knight takes f7
um okay bishop before queen e4 defends
the knight there
so okay knight f7 i think i explained
and now bishop c4 so we we pin the rook
to the king
and if black plays any other move we
just take with and we win the queen as
well
so knight g6 instead doesn't work
because after f takes g6
check i don't see the follow up guys i'm
not sure what you had in mind i mean
this check obviously just one takes
queen
even if the queen does give an h file
check the bishop can block it on h6
so that's not quite doesn't quite get
the job done i know what you're going
for i know the pattern you're going for
but it doesn't work here
i think the pattern i had a game many
many years ago
let me quickly pull this one up i know
what pattern people are going for it's
like this mate where you drive the king
you you sacrifice a piece for a pawn
in order to drive the king to the corner
and checkmate it
let me see if i can very quickly find
this game i just want to play one more
game after this one
this was an old game yeah you guys see
the final position but basically like
this kind of position occurs right you
notice that the king is in the corner
but it's got protection it's got pawns
and so we play knight takes g6 check we
stack a minor piece not the same thing
but we remove the covering
then we play queen h3 basically with
checkmate um well black can do this but
we made so that's just something to bear
in mind it doesn't quite work out
in you know in this game though
okay um so anyways here takes takes e5
wins the night
because there's just now i can't move
and the rest is pretty simple
um i mean here i think some people were
asking why not take the rook with check
but the queen just takes back that
trades
that that that is a trade white doesn't
want because we're trying to attack
so queen f5 bishop takes c7 is a nice
move
queen c7 allows f7 winning the rook with
checkmate
and uh h4 is a key move if he takes the
bishop now we go queen g6 and we take
the bishop
so if g takes h4 then was in that
painful shark
queen g4 four king the king in the rock
yeah so queen capture c7 there's queen
g6 oh and a beautiful idea after bishop
g7 guys
white can take on g7 why can play f7
and which move here wins the game
i am a bully and then we'll move on to
the next game
yeah queen g7 displacing the king
king is the worst blockader boom and the
king is just busted
all right silo you want to jump silas
simon you want to challenge me ten plus
five unrated please
okay that's basically the game the rest
was very simple i mean it just takes
lift the rook up rook g7 if takes takes
it's the same concept
check unseating the king and then queen
to h8 is just check me
so it's all the same kind of pattern
involving promotion combinations
involving promotion and pawns on
seventh rank that's something you can
practice with puzzles
and that basically wins
[Music]
you